bonjour pierre conesa merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors
tout d'abord que peut-on attendre de la
vie de gérald darmanin moscou je crois
que c'est la première étape si vous
voulez d'un dire des mesures
d'application d'aidé qui ont été
annoncées par le gouvernement français
c'est à dire expulsés ou ramener dans
leur pays des fichiers ms bon on sait
qu'il faut en général on laisser passer
consulaire et que beaucoup de pays
sinon qu'ils ont un bon contingent si
vous voulez des expulsables
en général les refuges dans particulier
les algériens donc cette étape avec
moscou va probablement consisté à
permettre de se débarrasser d'un certain
nombre de fiches et s venant des pays de
russie et est ce que moscou tout
simplement peut accepter justement le
retour de ces fichiers s d'origine
tchétchène je pense qu'il ya aucune
raison qu'il le refuse parce que ils ont
eux-mêmes suis plus à subir des
attentats si vous voulez dans le rouge
métro de moscou et s'est donc il ya un
terrorisme tchétchène comme il ya
d'ailleurs un autre nationalité mais le
cas des tchétchènes est évidemment celui
qui préoccupe le plus la russie fait
qu'on ait accordé l'asile politique
rappelez vous devez d'abord que cet
habitué de fête s'était vu refuser
l'asile politique et que c'est un juge
est passé outre la décision
administrative pour finalement accordé
la la ceinture d'un fusil politiquement
donc on a vu qu effectivement la famille
s'est désolidarisé de de l'enfant qui a
commis l'attentât mais enfin il reste on
est dans une situation où on voit bien
que il faut gérer les problèmes des flux
et des retours avec le gouvernement
d'origine et c'est ce qu'on va
probablement essayer de prédire avec
moscou aujourd'hui quel est l'état de la
coopération justement sur le sujet de
l'anti terrorisme entre la france et la
russie
je peux pas vous répondre précisément
parce qu'on peut pas dire que la
relation entre la france et la russie
soient spécialement excellent le
président macron a fait des efforts pour
se défaire si vous voulez de l'emprise
des américains sur la relation avec
moscou
donc il a lui-même essayer de normaliser
dans la relation officielle en
bilatérales si vous voulez mais il est
évident qu'il ya beaucoup de il faut
remonter un peu à la charge il faut
remonter à contre courant
et ça c'est quand même quelque chose qui
doit être saluée qui n'est pas le
suivisme absolu à l'égard des états unis
maintenant est-ce que ça va aller
jusqu'à des échanges n'en sais rien
ouais je sais justement la question que
j'allais vous poser est ce que cette
rencontre n'est pas aussi l'occasion
peut être de renforcer justement la
coopération à ce sujet un antiterrorisme
entre la france et la russie
écoutez c'est un des domaines
certainement qu'ils pourraient être
développées maintenant il ya d'autres
théâtres dans lesquelles les échanges de
renseignements serait utile parce que
rappelez vous le désastre on a laissé en
turquie en syrie en irak si vous voulez
et qu'on voit apparaître des turcs qui
sont aujourd'hui de plus en plus actifs
en particulier pour exterminer les
kurdes
donc les russes qui ont soutenu le
régime de damas
justement qu'ils ont permis de survivre
à la crise sont probablement dans une
situation où disons ils peuvent aménager
un retour de la france dans cette région
que faire dès des du retour de ces
tchétchènes ficher s en france que que
la russie va en faire ça je peux pas
vous dire ça dépend un peu de la nature
de des faits délictueux qui leur sont
reprochés c'est certain c'est que vous
savez notre droit d'asile à fonctionner
à l'envers paradoxalement c'est à dire
qu'on a accepté des gens qui étaient
parfois poursuivie chez eux pour des
faits criminels mais simplement qu'on
m'y risquer d'être maltraités par les
interrogatoires de police ou qui
souhaitent condamner à mort les ont leur
accorder leur refuse le statut de
réfugié politique
c'est comme ça qu'on a laissé se
constituer le camp de lodi ce temps en
bretagne vous souvenez où étaient réunis
un certain nombre d'islamistes
complètement féroce c'est complètement
fou moi je les entends du high park et
les anglais se sont rendus compte que
contrairement à ce qu'ils affirment et
ça ne l'est sanctuary sais pas si vous
voulez quand il ya eu les attentats de
londres
ils ont très rapidement et très
efficacement négocié le retour de ses
deux césar h
ça prouve que c'est possible et donc la
france doit avoir une attitude
exactement analogue à ce qui était fait
par londres c'est à dire introduire un
rapport de force avec des pays qui ne
veulent pas reprendre les ressortissants
qui sont actuellement sur notre
territoire n'ont plus droit au statut de
réfugié politique
merci beaucoup pire que les a d'abord
été
avec nous aujourd'hui sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes ancien
fonctionnaire et spécialiste des
questions stratégiques internationales
merci beaucoup